Devourer
I must devour are you
you have regained consciousness it's a
miracle
my name is Helen I have been asked to
take care of you your nurse
so to speak
you had broken bones everywhere at first
but we thought you were already dead do
you remember what happened to you
I remember Boise
you must save your strength
I'll finish you
that was most impressive
it seems you haven't forgotten your air
force training how do you know so much I
already told you I've been asked to take
care of him not only that I have
valuable information
you must find this man and take the
piece he has you are going to meet it if
you want to defeat bison you don't want
that
nicely meaty charge - no estimate on
recovery power/lock - went off over a
wide area damaging these seven parts of
the city as a result we've lost all
communications in those areas this is a
magnetic pulse caused by a high altitude
explosion but who would have such
advanced technology to cover this wide
of a range maybe it's related to the
missing hackers incident but we would
need to verify you always show up with
such perfect timing it's almost scary
your mission is to go to New York and
determine if there is any connection to
the missing hackers I'm coming with you
guy oh all right
generators coming on
much appreciated Chumlee
it's my pleasure